Jilly's with us Julie's in Cincinnati hi
Julie how are you hi Dave thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up well I'm a 60 year old
widow and I just found out a couple
weeks ago that my job is being
eliminated what do you do for a living
um what I've currently been doing is
I've been doing physician sales for one
of the large hospital systems here in
Cincinnati
how much do you man I make about $72,000
a year okay how long have you been doing
that I've been doing sales for about 20
years this is great oh I'm so glad they
kicked you out of the nest well
unfortunately Dave everything I'm
looking at requires a college degree
which I don't have
I oh you got better in college degree
you've been you know how to sell let me
just tell you you get your yeah yeah
better than a college degree how long
have you been selling for over 20 years
Oh kiddo you got a master's degree in
selling that's one of the most valuable
things out there I wouldn't let this
hold you listen you let a customer tell
you know when you're going in no that's
how you know how to sell right exactly
you just got the best product on the
earth to seller name's Julie I'm
terrified with fear right now I uh I
know that that's why I'm talking to you
like this I'm I've been sending resumes
out that's not gonna work
listen did you sit do you send mail it
you send little letters to your people
you're trying to sell to and just they
just always quickly respond easily no no
no you're selling Julie put change hats
okay take off the I'm afraid Widow
60-year old hat let's set that one over
to the side all right let's put on the
Hat of I'm a 20-year experienced proven
professional seller you're rock star I
hope so no they wouldn't have kept you
20 years if you weren't a rock star they
want to ditched you after two you had
people that worked around you they
weren't rock stars that aren't there
anymore already right
I was the only one left I boil there you
go
that means that you are the best of
everything they had right how do i how
do I stop stop stop
well stop you're not hearing me are you
I am I doubted myself and I I know what
I'm trying to say right you really
really really need to hear this you take
off that that devil screaming in your
ear that you somehow are vulnerable you
are listen you're a commodity kiddo
I mean you rip the most valuable people
on the planet are people who can smile
and interact with other people and cause
them to cause a transaction to occur I
look for people like you every day to
work in my organization all the time I
do but it's the Julie that was 18 months
ago walking in with a little bit of a
strat in a Doc's office or whatever you
were doing and you were making the sale
that's the Julie I need to wake back up
not the little one that's got her thumb
stuck in her mouth and scared right now
and that's where I'm at night why we
really wanted to talk to you because I
know I knew you would help me I just you
really need to hear me I am NOT just I'm
not just blowing in your ear kiddo I
mean really this is the truth you have a
marketable skill you have a really
really marketable skill the only thing I
could think of that might be more
marketable were you an IT developer
right now I mean that's a marketable
skill right now you can walk in off the
street and barely fog up a mirror and
get hired in places right now with that
you know but you know how to sell don't
you do you really know how to sell or
were they just keeping you because they
like you I love what I do I know no I
wanna I said do you know how to sell
absolutely okay then you got a new
product I need to sell myself yeah and
don't take no taking it no hey here's an
idea okay you got the best place on the
world that you want to if you do you add
to you onion
do you know of a place that you would do
anything you think it'd be like a home
run to go over there and work and they
might pay you like a hundred if you
really rocked it
do you know that place in your mind
right now - you can unit don't name it
on their hair but you know who I'm
talking about
yes okay I want you to call that place
until you get a meeting with the veto
the very important top officer you know
how to do that and I want you to end up
eyeball to eyeball somehow I take them
Donuts a pizza I don't know what you're
going to do but you're gonna get in
front of them and I want you to offer to
work for free for two months to prove
your value I am so confident in myself
mr. important person that's going to
hire me later that I will come in here
and show you how valuable I am I will
try that blown away you know it's called
it's called giving a sample mm-hmm
you're given a free sample you can do
this you just got change your brain yes
I do I've never I just feel like the rug
has been pulled out from under my feet
it's insulting to get fired
I really feel betrayed it's insulting
and it's emotional I mean it's like
going through a divorce that you didn't
work you know and so you kind of got to
look at those emotions and go those are
real but you know let me ask you this
have you ever made sales calls when you
had the flu absolutely - you know what
buckle up buttercup yep you do it in
spite of being pissed off right so you
have the stuff I just got to get you up
out of the mud where you can see again
I'm yeah I'm just so terrified I'm like
how am I gonna make it I you know I have
a house and I have a grandson that I
raised and you're going to make it great
because you're gonna end up making a
hundred instead of seventy these people
are fools so they're fools they're fools
I don't hope so I know so you know how
to sell it's an engine I'm gonna get out
there and hit the pavement tomorrow and
listen it's not the time but filling out
47,000 applications on monster.com I'm
talking about getting how you know how
to make a sale you have to get two human
beings to make a sale mm-hmm and it's in
person or it's on the phone and you know
somebody that knows somebody your
grandson's soccer coaches dad
is the president of XYZ and that's who
you hey I need to talk to him and we
share this in common our grandsons are
both over at the soccer field and you
know I don't know you know somebody that
knows somebody if you'll start thinking
about it and get yourself in front of
them and listen you SEL you've got you
you got you got a PhD man don't have a
college degree you twenty years of doing
this nobody makes it twenty years
nobody's that tough always got that kind
of moxie you strutting there and take
that job this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim
you